PROFESSOR: So now we start
on a new unit called counting
or combinatorics.
And it's about counting things.
Now one of the things that
happens when you're counting
is your typically adding
up a bunch of numbers
that you've counted
along the way.
And so you wind up needing
to deal with sums a lot.
And so let's start with those
mathematical preliminaries.
We're going to look at three
kinds of sums, arithmetic
sums, geometric sums,
and harmonic sums.
All of which come
up very regularly.
And they all have
reasonably nice formulas
that explain what they sum to.
Let's begin with the simplest
ones of arithmetic sums.
So there's an example.
This supposedly is
the kind of problem
that was assigned to children
in the the 18th century
to keep them busy in class.
And the great mathematician
Gauss, Carl Friedrich Gauss,
whom you know for magnetism
and from probability theory,
but also in fact the
inventor of congruence
and the number theory
that we've studied,
showed his brilliance
as a child prodigy.
When he was nine-years
old, supposedly, he
noticed that in that short
of numbers, that we just saw,
there were 30
numbers, and each one
was 13 greater than
the previous one.
The idea being that
the tutor didn't
want to go through the effort
of summing everything up.
He knew the trick to
get the sum quickly,
but he kept his
students busy for hours
doing that kind of problem.
I don't know whether that
this is a true story or not,
but it's a good story.
So let's go on with it.
So in other words,
what Gauss noticed
was that the numbers on that
page looked like 89 and 89
plus 13 down through the 30th
number 89 plus 29 times 13.
And then he saw how to get
the sum of a simple expression
for the value of this sum.
And the logic is that
let's call the first term F
and then the next term is F plus
2 d-- F plus d, where d is 13
and F is 89.
Next one would be F plus
2 d down to the end.
And I'm going to
call the last term L,
which is 89 plus 29 times 13.
And this would be L minus
d or 89 plus 28 times 13.
And let's call that sum A.
We don't know what it is yet,
but we're very quickly
going to derive it.
One of the standard tricks to
find nice formulas for sums
is to find a arithmetic
relation between the sum
and a slight
perturbation of the sum.
In this case, I'm just going
to write the sum backwards.
So it's the same
sum A, but written
where the first term is last
and the last term is first.
And now notice what happens
when I add up these two sums.
I get 2A of course.
But every one of these terms--
this is a F plus L. This
is a F plus d plus L minus D.
It's F plus L. This last one is
an F plus L.
Every one of these
pairwise subsums
comes out to be
F plus L. And now
we have a formula for the whole
series in my simple formula
that A is equal to the
sum of the first term
plus the last term divided by
2 times the number of terms.
By the way, the first term
plus the last term divided by 2
maybe is more memorable
if you remember
that it's the average term.
It's the average size term
times the number of terms.
And that's how you sum
up an arithmetic sum.
So we can wrap up with a
familiar example, namely
the sum of the
integers from 1 to n.
This is an arithmetic
series, starts with one.
And the d, that
is the difference
from successive terms is simply
1, 1 plus 1, 1 plus 1 plus 1
down to n.
And according to
our formula, it's
the first plus the last over
2 times the number of terms.
And we have that
familiar formula
for the sum of the
first n integers.